I find this fascinating so I was just
curious did you have a cubicle like your
own desk to really like digest this no
it was reading at home a reader is a
totally freelance job so at the time I
mean this really dates me a lot of the
work was actually in print so I would go
to the company that was working for they
would give me script or two or a stack
or a book printed on paper I would go
home I would write up the coverage
report and then I would actually really
early on I would put it on a disk on a
floppy disk I would save it and then I
would come back in and give them the
floppy disk and they would put it on
their computer into the server so that
the execs and president accompanying
stuff could access it you know but yeah
I was actually reading on paper now they
obviously just email a PDF and then it's
up to the reader who works at home
whether they want to print it out and
read it on paper or they want to read it
on their computer or tablet or whatever
and what would you say was the average
amount of you know coverage that you
were reading in a 24 hour period for one
thing like you said 600 pages for a
booklet that sounds like that maybe was
excessive it was yeah I when I was a
reader it I was in New York City so I
didn't read a ton of scripts at once
like readers in LA will come in and pick
up or not pick up these days but they'll
get 5 or 6 scripts at once and they'll
have two or three days maybe four to
turn them around okay so they have to
read all these scripts right coverage
reports and send them back in to their
employer whether it's an agency or a
production company with studio in my
case I never read that high of a volume
but let's say usually the turnaround was
two days so I'd get a script whether I
got a script or two or three let's say I
got them on Monday they would be due by
Wednesday but what was challenging and
good because it paid more money was the
overnight jobs so if they needed
something overnight it would be tougher
because I would get less
sleep that night and I would really have
to blast this thing out and send it in
in the morning or let's say by noon if
it wasn't as urgent maybe by the end of
the day the next day but it would pay a
little bit more for overnight jobs so I
always like those and so what did you
start to learn about really dissecting
something because I mean are you like
speed reading I does one finish
something and then do coverage on it
within a two day period like that well
some readers might take notes as they go
they might write notes in the margins if
they're reading on paper but after a
while I just I just internalized my
thoughts and I actually had what I
called the brain dump which is for that
time period of when I was focusing on
this piece of material whether 24 hours
48 hours I would remember everything
about it I mean I would be reading fast
but I would be absorbing everything
right and I had been doing this for a
long time so I've seen the patterns in
structure and in writing and so I know
immediately this is a cliche or this
page is too dense this dialogue is too
on the nose
so I'm noting that as I'm reading really
fast even though I'm reading fast I'm
catching these things and then when I'm
done I immediately would write up the
synopsis while it was fresh in my head
and then I would write up my one page of
comments but the interesting thing was
and the reason I call it the brain dump
was the next day or two days later a
week later I didn't remember all that
detail because I was just my brain was
focused on this one 48-hour period you
have to do coverage on this piece of
material so keep it in your brain for 48
hours and then after that dumb most of
it you know I mean the great scripts and
the great books that I read on the job I
still do remember you know elements of
them I mean I still remember lines from
like The Sixth Sense script and from a
few other scripts and and some books but
generally a reader is just evaluating it
for one read and it's in that 124
48 hour period they're not doing pages
pages of notes they're not meeting with
the writer you know this isn't
development they're just evaluating one
read after it comes in the door and
they're handing their report in and then
from there they don't really know where
it goes
you